so
[Music]
so i have some very exciting news for
you i'm back with a new film profile
made after the fujifilm maternal
simulation i've been very busy lately
and had very little time on hand but i
really wanted to make this video to
share with you these settings and how
you can get the same look using the
creative lut
also i will show you how to replicate
the cine steel 800 look so watch the
whole video to find out how
a little bit about the profile i'm
absolutely in love with the profile is
just gorgeous in terms of contrast and
how it renders colors i've been testing
it for a week or two in multiple
scenarios and lighting conditions and
it's just crazy good
last weekend actually i was at a party
and took a bunch of pictures with this
profile and the colors were so good that
i didn't even feel the need to edit them
so i just used the jpegs
it handles underexposing and
overexposing very very well with soft
gradations and pleasing colors
with most of my previous film profiles i
just like to keep the image a little bit
underexposed but with this profile being
so versatile i can just expose both ways
my only complaint with this profile is
that it shifts the yellow towards green
very much when overexposed and sometimes
it can give weird hues in the highlights
in some situations this is caused by the
c4 gamma generally that's the reason why
i usually avoided using destiny 4
because if you have watched my other
videos on film simulation for sony
cameras you can notice that none of the
film simulations that i've made is based
on 74 but this time i needed a more
contrasty look
also cine4 is probably the noisiest from
all cine gammas it's not a big issue if
you enjoy the grain but for the cleanest
image i will still use new one and
that's good to keep in mind as a
reference in this video the next iso
used was 2500 with a f 2.8 lens
many of you asked for a tutorial on how
to shoot these film profiles to get a
similar look i'm currently working on a
video explaining
general settings on how i shoot each
profile and i hope to finish it next
week subscribe to be notified about the
video when it comes out so now let's get
the cine steel look
this is the raw footage from the camera
shot on the alternate film profile and
grade it using the creative lut pack to
get even closer to the film look all you
have to do is choose the halation
strength from the creative lut folder
and apply it to the footage is that easy
to adjust the hilation just right click
on the node open the compound node and
on this layer adjust the red curve to
limit or extend the affected area you
can find these on my website linked down
below
you can see it looks really good out of
the camera and it's saving me a lot of
time that i would have spent on color
grading the way you can achieve this
cold cyan color is by shooting below
2500 kelvin
if you shoot sony you know the minimum
kelvin you can choose manually is 2500
but if you make a custom white balance
you can actually go even lower or higher
than the manual limits and i'll show you
exactly how you can do that
go into the color temperature menu you
can do that by going into the photo icon
at page 12 on the sony a7v but i
recommend assigning it to a button so
it's one step away in any given
situation i assign this menu to the
joystick just by clicking it so i can
easily access it at any time that is a
life saver in many occasions scroll down
to a custom balance press ok and now
find something yellow and fill the whole
screen with it and now press the middle
point
now the camera will try to correct the
yellow tint in the image and will
compensate by going under 2500 kelvin
save this color as a custom you can
create three of these custom colors and
trust me they are very helpful not only
for film colors but for day to day
shooting so use this function i've also
saved the creative lut for footage that
is shot on regular kelvin so you can
just drag and drop it on any footage
together with all the original grades
that i've used for the initial video
make sure to check them out and hit the
like button if you like this eterna
profile
to save this simulation just go into the
menu and find picture profile on the a7
iii is at page 12 in the image icon hit
ok press right to enter the menu and
there you can find all the settings that
you need the settings for this profile
are free but testing creating these
profiles and editing the videos take a
lot of time so please consider
supporting the channel by buying the
creative lots or by buying me a coffee i
appreciate your support and that's why
for the next month the less will be 50
off like subscribe if you haven't
already and thanks again for watching
see you soon